為什麼三十歲以上的你，你會覺得好像越運動越練越卡這件事情?
那今天這支影片我們會針對三十歲以上的人，我們來討論一下這個問題。
可能你有運動習慣，或者是你可能沒有。那沒關係，先不論你有沒有在運動,
那麼腰痠背痛，肩頸僵硬這件事情，你是不是有?
比如說你會很容易感受到駝背啊，然後圓肩啊，頸前引這件事情
但是其實不只是因為你坐太久 不是因為你低頭滑手機這件事情 而是你身體正在用錯的方式動
所以這個對我們來說就叫做所謂的代償 那今天這支影片我們會先討論三件事
然後，呃，我是 Jamie 我有 12 年的教學經驗 所以 所以其實我看過各個大大小小的學生
然後我看過各種的個案 其實大部分的人都會有個問題 比如說像上班族好了 或者是自由工作接案者
只要你是長時間在電腦前面需要工作的人 其實基本上你們都會有這個狀況
那今天我們就是花一點時間 然後來討論一下這件事情 所謂的代償是什麼
我覺得白話文應該 我今天想要我的背可以去幫助我出力
但是我的背沒有辦法被啟動 反而用上斜方肌 就是大家會想要打漏毒的地方 然後來幫我出力
那如果今天出的力是我不想要它出的地方 那就叫做所謂的代償
那以現代我都會跟學生講說 這可能像是文明病 像是比如說肩頸僵硬啊，然後腰痠啊
然後肩膀前移這件事情，或者是你的骨盆有點前傾的情況
你以為是你坐太久，但其實是因為你的 比如說前後或者是左右力量的不平均
所以導致身體代償 那一個最實際的例子應該是 代償為什麼這件事情會讓你越動越痠
比如說逛街停，就是提 shopping bag，就是你們購物的東西,
然後或者是比如說出國啊，然後扛行李啊，或者是久坐,
然後再站起來的這個情況下，其實都叫做代償。 因為如果今天你試想一下，你現在去出國，然後在外面逛街的時候,
可是你單邊提著一個行李重物,
或者是比如說你提著你 shopping 的購物袋也好 那你是不是一定要靠單邊核心的力量處理
不然的話如果你沒有靠單邊核心處理 你的重量就會被往下帶 所以如果我這邊被往下帶的話 那我這邊就會比較高
所以它兩邊不平衡的情況下 就這個東西就是我們所謂的帶長
那我們要如何解決這件事情呢? 為什麼我要解決 因為假設 如果你今天有代償這個行為 那麼你就會非常容易受傷
像有些學生他們今天跟我講說 喔 我今天有一點那個 腰閃到
就是拿一個東西然後怎麼樣怎麼樣 或者是今天你可能在做什麼事情
然後突然覺得 欸 卡一下 欸 怎麼這邊緊緊的 或是什麼肩膀卡一下
膝蓋卡一下 這種情況 其實都會跟我們的代償很有關係 當然不只這個原因啦
只是這會是其中一部分的原因 那麼 三 我們要怎麼讓身體重新啟動這件事情
那這件事情 這個接下來的影片我會講到一些部分的動作 是你在家可以做的
那如果今天我想用這塊出力 這塊肌肉出力 就是剛剛講的 那就是對的 但如果你不想要 但卻用了，那就叫做所謂的代償
也就是說如果今天我在拿逛街 這是一個最實際的例子 我在逛街的時候，然後我覺得肩頸很痠
我覺得腰很痠 但是本來應該要處理的是你的腹部啊 你的核心啊，你的軀幹啊 但是當它沒有力量的時候
這件事情就會影響到我的整個肩頸 所以如果你會覺得長期下來
你的肩膀很痠痛 然後你覺得你的姿勢不良，你有駝背的問題 或是坐辦公室坐久，然後你會腰痠的話
那今天這支影片你一定要把它看完 因為這個就叫做所謂的代償 那動作做完了，可是其實你都是在用錯誤的方式
在處理這件事情 那其實我會說 10 個女性當中呢
有 10 個 十個女性當中有八個都在待場，只是她們自己不知道這件事情而已
那你每天都在做這幾件事情，比如說你可能是媽媽 可能你抱小孩，或是你有一隻寵物，或是比較重的寵物，然後你要抱牠們
但這其實都需要靠我們的身體的核心軀幹出力
那逛街就是剛剛上述提到的東西 那再來話說 手機、看電腦這件事情，你就是會一直想要往前嘛，對吧?
那上臂就會變得比較緊繃，所以這勢必的情況下是
我的胸椎的活動度就會比較弱 那很多人就會因為這件事情而突然的受傷
或者是突然的閃到腰，突然的怎麼樣，對 然後更重要的事情是，這就會影響到你的工作效率
你有可能一整天下來，你就會變得非常的不舒服 然後呢，你可能更想要有好的線條
可是因為你的體態姿勢實在是太差了 那你就更不用說這些線條了 甚至搞不好連你練起來都會有困難
因為骨盆前傾這件事情有可能我就會影響到 我的臀部的力量啊 或者是我的腿後側肌群啊 或者是我的核心力量啊這件事情
那其實每一次的動 都是讓我的身體出錯方向，練錯方向 這個其實是像我有時候在觀察我學生的時候
我就會發現我的學生們其實很多人都有這樣子的問題 那我在課程上面除了去加強他們比較弱的肌肉之外
再來就是要去放鬆他們比較緊繃的肌肉 又或者是說我可以透過其他訓練的方式
一些矯正性訓 來去放鬆他比較 緊繃的肌肉這件事情我一樣有辦法做到這件事情
那緊繃的肌肉很多是比如說肩頸啊腰啊腿後側啊然後你會覺得好像越活動
越緊 可是明明你該用的地方就是你的 腹部啊 然後你的屁股的臀肌啊 然後跟你肩胛附近比如說像是前肢肌這個需要
比較穩定的肌肉或者是闊背的這個位置 那他們越來越弱的情況下 就會讓你肩頸痠痛跟腰痠還有骨盆牽體這件事情
越來越明顯 甚至其實如果你是現在有在上教練課的人 或者是你準備想要去上教練課的人
你會發現說在教練課的過程當中 你會很容易、更容易的可以發現這些問題
可能因為你平常 平常在做辦公室的情況下，在做工作的情況下 我的身體其實是最低耗能在做這件事情，也就是說
今天我是心裡要承受很大的壓力 然後我的手指要控制滑鼠鍵盤
這件事情本身的勞動而已 然後還有思考的勞動 但是我要用運動的時候來做這件事情，我的身體的耗能相對來
就會比較大嘛，坐辦公室相對來說坐著不動是比較輕的 所以在運動的過程中有時候會反映出你原本就有的問題
像我有些學生是，他們來上課之後然後才發現 欸，他好像做這個動作的時候會特別的明顯覺得下背特別不舒服
或是特別緊繃 但是其實是錯的，因為他根本不知道他要怎麼樣用正確的方式來處理
那，其實呢，呃，睡眠 訓練過頭這件事情，我會覺得如果你今天不是個運動員 你今天不是個選手的情況下
那我會覺得大部分的人，如果一個禮拜四練個一到三天的情況下 都只是叫做適當訓練，甚至一次還太少
我覺得二到三次叫做適當訓練 而不叫過度訓練 所以如果你覺得你在練的運動的當下，你會覺得不舒服
那就代表說你的身體其實是用錯方式了 那你越練越累，然後你越來越痠，可是你卻沒有看到進步
然後最後你就會覺得，啊算了，反正我不適合運動啦 但其實不是你不適合，只是你不知道你要怎麼開始去做這件事情而已這樣
那這邊的話，我提供了四個東西
比如說你彎腰撿東西 會不會覺得腰痠 然後或者是你蹲下來穿鞋的時候
你可以試想一下 你的膝蓋會往內扣 還是你會打開呢?
那又或者是說比如說 我在拿東西 這邊舉的例子是收行李 但是也有可能是比如說我在廚房上
我要拿一個東西的時候 我會不會這樣子
去拿 但是你們想喔，你們看喔，如果今天我把手伸直 我可以到這個角度上
但是如果今天我是肩膀牽引的情況下 你看
這樣就太不高了吧 對不對 這樣就太不高了 他的角度相對來說就會被受到限制
或者是說你的單腳站啊，穿襪子會晃這件事情 當然骨盆屁股沒力這個是一件很正常的事情
可是其實當然我們還要去檢查其他穩定關節啊的情況下
比如說是不是腳踝穩定度會比較弱啊等等的 其實你就可以從這幾個測驗來去知道
當然這是一個比較簡單的 只是你可以大概對這個東西有個概念 那我希望大家就是都能保持運動習慣
因為其實保持運動習慣這件事情是人非常需要做的事情
然後 然後我們為了保護我們自己的身體不要受傷 所以這支影片你真的非常的必看 因為首先你要先對這些東西有一個認知
那麼我們要怎麼去判斷這件事情呢? 首先我們就是 呃 我這邊有出一個就是實體的 呃 自體測驗
所以你只要 15 分鐘的時候你在家就可以做完了 那這個測驗結束之後
你大概會知道你的身體狀況 你會有一點點概念 那先處理一些需要處理的東西 比如說比較緊繃的肌肉
但是這邊我會說 你先處理緊繃的肌肉這件事情 其實並沒有辦法幫你真的導正 真的導正這件事情
讓代償歸零這件事情 因為所有比較緊繃的地方
或者是太弱的地方 其實最根本的道理都是 因為肌肉
可能肌肉失衡所導致的 可能是左右失衡 可能是上下失衡 那這件事情你就需要去練習一些基本的動作
就像重量訓練 你可能可以從輕重量多次數慢慢練 然後再慢慢疊加上去 而你練的東西是 我要如何控制我自己的身體 我要如何掌控我自己的身體 然後我要如何增加我的身體的敏感度跟感受度
才可以讓 可以讓我不要那麼容易受傷 那再來是 如果你想要擺脫肩頸痠痛啊
腰痠背痛這件事情 確實 你先測完我跟你們說的那個題目之後
你們就會知道你們自己在帶上什麼 那 逛街時比如說換手提 就是購物袋
這件事情 我覺得這跟斜背、側背包是一樣的概念 偶爾要換邊背
這樣他才不會那麼 不會導致兩邊的力量一直失衡 要不就是用雙肩包來取代這件事情
但當然啦，我說為了好看的話 我們還是會單肩背 所以這時候我們要去增加的是
我們身體的平衡跟協調能力就會非常的重要 像我自己的訓練裡面 其實我做了蠻多穩定性的動作
因為我以前打跆拳道的時候 我的腳踝有韌帶鬆脫的問題 我有受過傷 然後我就有發現說
當我右腳在站起來 單力的時候會很容易不平衡 那這個狀況會發生在什麼生活的例子呢?
就是如果你是一個走路走久 然後你會很容易腳踝扭到的話 你會很容易就是跌倒的話
那這個東西你就要放在心上一下 對 然後所以呢我們每天呢 就是可以做一些就是放鬆頸椎、胸椎
髖關節的一些活動 那這裡其實我會蠻推薦動態暖身 那至於動態暖身是什麼呢?
這個就是在實體一對一的課程裡面 我才會講到這件事情這樣
那好，這支影片呢 短短的只有十幾分鐘 但是基本上這十幾分鐘看完之後 你會對代償這件事情更有一個概念
其實有時候你只是需要 讓你的身體重新啟動 重新出發
然後讓運動這件事情真正的融入你的生活裡面 所以其實你需要做的事情就只有了解你的身體的狀況
然後試著去改變它這樣 那我這邊提供就是幾個服務
如果說你有這個需求的話 那你在底下留言打 LIFE
我就會傳給你就是連結的部分 對，你們可以先追蹤我的 IG
然後呢 留言打 LIVE 然後我就會私訊給你連結 那或者是
如果說今天你覺得這個東西測完了 你覺得還不夠 你想要有人可以幫助你做這件事情的話
因為像我最近的個案其實有蠻多 是想要調整肩頸痠痛的問題
然後或是腰痠背痛這樣 然後有些人可能是比如說血跡
他們都會去滑雪 然後就會發現說 自己會用到一些不太正確的肌肉的情況下
那如果你想要我幫你看動作 然後規劃接下來的訓練的話 那我會推薦的是預約 60 分鐘的深度體態評估
那在這個評估當中 我會告訴你說，喔你現在的問題大概是什麼 然後我們可以怎麼樣的去訓練跟怎麼樣的去做
那接下來陸陸續續我會出更多這種影片 那你可以去 記得要訂閱我的 Youtube
那麼如果有問題的話 你們都可以在底下留言 然後我會回你們，就這樣
掰掰